I did miss the Thunder buddy song was it
everyone go to be in the second one it
it was yeah there was that there was a
scene where Joe I'd you take it out it's
you know you're when you're two and a
half hours long in your first cut you
have to you know show mercy to the
audience it's but it was in there yeah
there was a scene where John and Ted
sing the Thunder buddy song it's an
awful singing night long
are you ready okay sure
Cindy Juana Carson oh yeah how about
that one two three four when you hear
the sound of thunder don't you get too
scared
just grab your Thunder buddies and say
these magic words you thunder you
can suck my dick you can't get me
thunder cuz you just got first
Oh
you're with the Shan don't be
discouraged
can you really feel you 57 big nips okay
I was Ola vader kenobi palpatine
calrissian balboa rambo griswold
stepford bickle gump corleone wonka
Sivaji lebowski venkman spengler stands
reserved Zhukova like the higgins do